so
[Music]
all the conditions for its production
are to hand and this totality of its
conditions constitutes its coming to be
its notion or the production of it in
principle
the circle of the creations of art
embraces the forms in which absolute
substance has externalized itself
absolute substance
is in the form of individuality as a
thing an object of sensuous
consciousness that simply is as pure
language or the coming to be of a shape
whose existence does not go outside the
self but is purely a vanishing object as
immediate unity with the universal
self-consciousness in its inspiration
and as a mediated unity in the act of
the cult as a beautiful self-like
corporeality and lastly
as existence raised into an ideational
presentation and the expansion of this
existence into a world which finally
collects itself together into a
universality which is at the same time a
pure certainty of itself
these forms and on the other side the
world of the person and of law the
destructive ferocity of the freed
elements of the content as also the
person as thought in stoicism and as the
unstable restlessness of the skeptical
consciousness constitute the audience or
periphery of shapes which stands
impatiently expectant around the
birthplace of spirit as it becomes
self-consciousness that is round the
manger at bethlehem
the grief and longing of the unhappy
self-consciousness which permeates them
all is their center and the common birth
pain of its emergence the simplicity of
the pure notion which contains those
forms as its moments
paragraph
754 is taking all that's been going on
in this section and the paragraphs
leading up to this in the revealed
religion and also
the very ending of religion as
art
and bringing them together into kind of
a
not and hegel is telling us something
very important here
in the very first sentence talking about
a totality a totalitat in german
and uh the conditions constituting it's
coming to be at the verdan right so he
says all the conditions for its
production what's it well the new shape
of consciousness that we're moving into
are
to hand for
for hondon and this totality of its
conditions constitutes
it's coming to be its notion
or the production of it in principle and
here what we're dealing with
is notion or concept or grief but in its
really as it's unfolding kind of stages
but it's bringing together everything
that's happened
so far in two different
ways it's
bringing together all the positive
expressions
of religion as art the
ethical spirit working its way through
religion as uh the religion of a people
a folk right
folk and then it's um
looking at the
negative side of it as well that has
come out
in the final part of the religion as a
art
section
with comedy and all the stuff that
happened with tragedy as well but also
bringing back in uh stoicism skepticism
the unhappy consciousness so all of this
stuff that we've looked at so far is now
coming into a different light
and it's going to lead historically
to the
establishment and the
proliferation and further development of
a new kind
of religion
as well as a development of human
consciousness for
hegel so he tells us that the circle the
kiss of the creations and now creations
uh you know
i don't know about this translation the
hair for bringing
right the
bringing forward uh of art of course all
these
the creation puts a little bit too much
emphasis i think on the side of the
creator
and we need to think about these as ways
in which spirit has brought something
out of itself and in relation to a
nature that it's
increasingly transforming
so that
human beings could understand their
relation to the divine and he rattles
off a number of different representative
developments that we should look at
briefly so he says
absolute substance
has externalized itself in these
different forms
in the form of individuality as a
thing an object of sensuous
consciousness that simply
is and before we go on to look at the
examples that he he brings up we might
go back to the earlier part of the
religion section
and think about nature religion right
it is externalizing itself that is
absolute spirit or absolute substance is
externalizing itself humanity is
externalizing itself in
seeing religion
and the divine object in
things that are not it
which then it appropriates and turns
into
religious objects and now he says pure
language that's kind of an interesting
thing to to bring in there and what are
we thinking about there i mean the
closest analogy i would say would be to
the
focus on
light the religion of light right but
light is inarticulate it shows but it
doesn't speak
uh and then we have the coming to be of
a shape whose existence does not go
outside the self
but is
purely a vanishing object and you know
this is
this vanishing idea has come up a lot in
hegel's discussions
right
the object doesn't really vanish but we
could say the
significance the understanding the
investment
of the object dwindles away
and this is part of the progress of
religion according to hegel hegel views
religion as developmental
right then we have
immediate unity with the universal
self-consciousness in its inspiration
and we can see that
that immediate unity is is
involved in each of these
individualities thing pure language
vanishing object
then we get to something more advanced
we saw in the
religion section
in the religion as a work of art right
the religion of art
that the cult the cultists in german
plays an incredibly important role of
mediating mediating between the
individual and the god but also the
individual and other individuals and
through generations there's the cult
provides a locus where human beings can
encounter the god
with each other in a new and important
way
then we had a beautiful self-like
corporeality this is towards the end of
the
second
main part of religion as art section
and you know the dancer the the ex the
expression in the human being and then
we get to
what the what we've traversed earlier an
existence raised into an idiotional
presentation we're going to come back to
that and the expansion of this existence
into a world
which finally collects itself into a
universality which is at the same time a
pure certainty of itself and here we
have
you know greek epic tragedy and comedy
or language
now
ideational
i mean that's just fourstellang i don't
know why we miller didn't just say
representation or picture language or
something like that but
we shouldn't be misled by the english
translation here this is just for
stellang right and so epic and tragedy
though those are very complex for
sterling
now what happens after this
he says these forms
and on the other side so we have an
opposition here
the world of person
and of law
rex right
the destructive ferocity of the freed
elements of the content as also the
person is thought in stoicism and the
unstable restlessness of the skeptical
consciousness
so
what do we got going on here well we've
got this
all these different interesting positive
expressions of religion which in the
last paragraph we saw have essentially
lost their
capacity to move us
because we're not from that time and
they've lost their capacity to move
others as well
in that time
and then we've got the destructive
ferocity of the freed elements the
things that we were seeing at the very
end
of the second main
section as comedy came to the fore and
we saw that comedy is not just laugh
laugh giggle giggle it is this
destructive
uh you know bringing men and gods down
sort of development
now notice what else he's saying here
though the person as thought in stoicism
go back to the stoicism section
don't worry about whether hegel got
stoicism right or not because in many
respects he didn't
hegel thinks that the importance of
stoicism was establishing a kind of
abstract freedom of the human being as a
thinker who could withdraw from
a hostile world that disappoints their
desire their beginner right which is at
the essence of self-consciousness so
it's a strategy
and in in many respects it's a it's a
failure strategy
but it does have
cultural effects
then we have the unstable restlessness
the you know wildness the insanity even
of the skeptical consciousness which is
you know not only tearing other things
down removing their self-certainty but
is also uncertain of where it is itself
going
and then we have what
these constitute the and again
there's a lot going on here with the
translation with miller in this place he
talks about an audience and why talking
about an audience i think because that
goes back to what was going on in the
earlier section um where the spectator
was important but maybe we don't have to
think about audience that is an
interpolation by miller the word that
hegel is actually using is periphery and
it's just the german cognate for it you
know periphery right
and what's really interesting here is
that he says that these so all of this
stuff
and all the stuff on this side if we
read it lexically
constitute they mock and house right
so they they
make in a way to place
publicly to place externally
a periphery so a periphery is it could
be a circle it could be a square it
could be whatever you want but it's it's
a outer border
now he says of shapes gestalten
so i mean gestaltine could be read in
two different ways here it could be
looked at as like each one of these is a
shape of consciousness which indeed is
what they are
or we could think of them in a more
figurative way as like figures
that are all around together like
statuary or
you know
people or whatever that are that are
constituting this periphery
now they are an audience they are
looking on right and they're looking on
in a way
seeing that they
[Music]
they have their fulfillment in something
else so he goes on and he says that
they stand impatiently expected around
the birthplace of spirit as it becomes
self-consciousness so that's what we're
talking about here now you could say
well wait a second hasn't spirit become
self-consciousness over and over again
there's an entire
self-consciousness section which
includes of course stoicism and
skepticism and the master slave
dialectic yeah yeah that's true
it's becoming self-consciousness in a
different way
in this final revealed religion
section so it's not becoming
self-consciousness for the first time
it's becoming self-consciousness
as
more of self-consciousness
or you could say in an intensified
manner
self-self-consciousness if you like if
you want to be a little jokey about it
now miller interpolates here as well
round the manger aunt bethlehem i i
think this is jumping the gun a bit
yes that's where we're going with this
um
christ is going to be an incredibly
important figure in the revealed
religion but that's not happening
in any developed way quite yet so i mean
it's okay to look ahead
are these expectant shapes hanging
around bethlehem
like a you know manger scene or
something like that i don't think so i
mean most people historically at the
time that christ was born or jesus was
born jesus of of uh born in bethlehem
jesus of nazareth the carpenter
all this sort of stuff that we can say
most people had no clue who this guy was
and even after his ministry most people
had no clue who he was in the ancient
world it took an entire movement to grow
out of it so this might be anticipating
a bit too much
but what's really interesting after this
is he talks again about the unhappy
self-consciousness which permeates them
all
is their center and the common birth
pain
of
its emergence the simplicity of the pure
notion right so we got that again
which contains those forms as its moment
so we have a totality again a totality
not just of the circle of creations but
of all of this stuff going on as well
and now notice that he uses two terms
here
that are really quite important the
grief
so schmeartz
could be pain
grief is fine i guess and then longing
zen
right uh
that is is a good way to think about it
there is an affective
relation here an affect a way in which
the being of things is being revealed to
us
in pain
and or sorrow
and in
longing that is not being yet fulfilled
and i think that's that's a really
important point spirit is not some
spirit becoming self-consciousness
through the unhappy self-consciousness
and through the realization of the
failure of all of these things as they
brought the spirit forward and
further
is not something purely cognitive it is
something
through which we could say the affects
enter
living history
spirit has it at the two sides which are
presented above as two converse
propositions one is this that substance
alienates itself from itself and becomes
self-consciousness
the other is the converse that
self-consciousness alienates itself from
itself and gives itself the nature of
the thing or makes itself a universal
self both sides have in this way
encountered each other and through this
encounter their true union has come into
being
the externalization or kenosis of
substance its growth into
self-consciousness expresses the
transition into the opposite the
unconscious transition of necessity in
other words that substance is in itself
self-consciousness
conversely the externalization of
self-consciousness expresses this
that it is in itself the universal
essence or
since the self is pure being for self
which in its opposite communes with
itself that it is just because substance
is self-consciousness for the self that
it is spirit
of this spirit which has abandoned the
form of substance and enters existence
in the shape of self-consciousness it
may therefore be said if we wish to
employ relationships derived from
natural generation that it has an actual
mother but an implicit father for
actuality or self-consciousness in the
in itself as substance are it's two
moments through which reciprocal whose
reciprocal externalization each becoming
the other spirit comes into existence as
this their unity
in paragraph
755 what we see hegel doing is again
providing a summary of where we are and
showing where we're going in this
section
and he's doing so in a very metaphysical
very abstract way quite different than
the
more
historically
content-oriented
manner in which he has been leading up
to this but this is quite important i
think to
unpack
and so he tells us spirit or rather it
right which is what was talked about in
the last paragraph has in it the
two sides the zeitge the aspects
which are presented above now presented
here is for gestalt so this is worth
coming back to and lingering on and we
will in just a moment
as two converse propositions and these
are kind of longish propositions um
propositions um formulations is another
way we can think of it there's some sort
of lexical some sort of linguistic
expression that is is supposed to
connect us to the thought of what is
happening in thought
and what are these two well uh there's
substance alienates itself from itself
and becomes self-consciousness there's
one
proposition one zots for you
and then the other one is a little bit
longer self-consciousness alienates
itself from itself and gives itself the
nature of the thing or makes itself a
universal self
totally clear right well these are very
abstract propositions as well and
they're not abstract in the sense of
like being about genera and species and
definitions
this is something quite different
instead so we have to
unpack these a little bit and i do want
to attend to
the language right there is a lot of um
use of this this term and oi song right
and oysters and there's and zeiner in
here so there's all this intensification
and reflection going on
and you could you could read and also an
oyster as
alienating itself although that's also
like and i'm doing right becoming
alien to itself and also as
externalizing
making itself come out of itself
so there's a lot of interesting
connotations
here
substance
is one of the things that hegel talks
about all the time and typically when we
think about substance we're thinking
about it as
that which has
being in itself right on zigzag and he
uses that term a little bit later to
talk about the father
in a way that miller translates a bit
confusingly
substance doesn't have
at least at first consciousness let
alone self-consciousness although we see
that part of what hegel is sketching out
here is how substance does in fact
become conscious and substance could be
the substance of a chalkboard it can
also be the ethical substance so it's a
vast term that means a lot of different
things
self-consciousness we've got in there i
don't think we need to talk about that
too much but then he's going to talk
about universal self making itself the
nature of a thing and notice that
there's an agency
or at least a
causality
of unpacking of unfolding of and oisong
involved here so he tells us
substance alienates itself from itself
and becomes
self-consciousness
okay well that is a process that we've
seen developing
self-consciousness is
in fact what we human beings are we
recognize that
already in the self-consciousness
section and you could say that
the
process of the phenomenology is not
simply the development of consciousness
but the development of
self-consciousness
as a form of consciousness right so that
is
i think that's fairly straightforward at
this point right um it does have to
substance has to
become more than
just what it is in itself
in order to become self-consciousness
there's a dialectic here of the in
itself and the four itself that it
totally prefigures what's happening for
example and starts being in nothingness
in the early sections of it
then we have this longer one
self-consciousness alienates
itself
from itself
what does that mean
this is in part the historical process
and also the interpersonal process that
has been taking place
from the self-consciousness
section on in explicit forms and you can
also read it into what's happening
in the consciousness section in certain
ways that's just a suggestion we don't
need to explore that
but definitely it's happening in the
self-consciousness section definitely
it's happening in the reason section i
would say from the time that we get to
uh the phrenology onward all the way
into the very you know interesting
ethical stuff that's being discussed in
the reason section the whole of spirit
all of religion
self-consciousness alienates itself from
itself
and gives itself the nature of the thing
it treats itself as if it is a thing
even though it's not a
thing
as such an agency less intention-less
thing it is still self-consciousness
but it makes itself
as well
into a universal self this is part of
the nature
of self-consciousness each person
is you could say at risk of transforming
themselves into a universal self that is
not the real universal self
but also we have the opportunity of
finding ourselves within a something
that we say is bigger than us right
bigger than just myself
so
these are both
propositions zetsa and they are opposed
to each other they're opposed to each
other here on the page linguistically
conceptually
in representation
and then
he says that
both sides
have in this way in what way well
through these
propositions which are no longer just
propositions
they are
representations of
the reality
of things
both sides have encountered each other
now this is interesting so encounter i
think that's a great translation on
miller's part i haven't patched him
first translations we need to recognize
when he's getting things right
and gegen gekkoman right so
coleman uh to come to arrive to
go to a
place a place of
encountering each other and gagan being
opposed to being in front of they both
encounter and realize each other a
little bit later on hegel will use this
term reciprocal right and i think that
that's that's quite important here so he
tells us that both sides have
encountered each other through this
encounter their true union for anigeng
has come into being
the externalization and here you know
miller can't resist uh adding some extra
stuff in or kenosis the emptying right
kenosis is a theological term that's
used of the emptying of jesus christ as
savior
uh through the crucifixion which hagel's
going to talk about later so we'll just
leave that alone externalization
of substance
it's growth into self-consciousness
expresses what
the transition into the opposite the
unconscious
transition the uber gang going from one
thing to another going over you could
say
of necessity not vending kite
necessity itself
is not just
the you know brute thing that we
often treat it as this is not greek anon
k you know the necessity that we
view as sort of a blind necessity
necessity for hegel
this is a tricky term right and we've
talked about this quite a lot through
the course of this commentary in earlier
paragraphs
going on he says
what is this unconscious transition of
necessity in other words
that substance
is in itself
self-consciousness
it was there from the beginning
we did recognize it when we treated the
human being
as
self-consciousness in the
self-consciousness section that this is
of the essence of humanity that we are
self-consciousness in relation to and
other actually many many other others
and others to those others and and on
and on and on right and we're motivated
by the geared up by desire or hunger for
what for recognition on air cannon
that's all kind of
read in here that's all part of what it
is to be
substance at least the kind of substance
that we are and that exists in history
what about this other proposition
self-consciousness alienates itself from
itself
well
this leads us to the realization that
self-consciousness is spirit and this
can be expressed in this sort of chain
substance to self-consciousness to self
to spirit and here's what hegel has to
say
conversely
the externalization of
self-consciousness expresses this that
it is in itself the universal essence or
since the self is pure being for self
right
for six zen which in its opposite
communes with itself that it is just
because substance is self-consciousness
so because of this part right here
because
substance is self-consciousness
for the self
now we have a third thing being brought
in here but it's not something radically
different it is a you could say the self
is in some respect bringing together in
their opposition and in the transition
uh substance to self-consciousness right
so
self-consciousness substances
self-consciousness for the self because
this it is spirit
of this spirit he says which is
abandoned the form of substance and
enters existence in the shape of
self-consciousness
that is how spirit has to manifest
itself
right
there's a necessity involved there and
the necessity is don't just be substance
be self-conscious
here is where hegel gets to the talk
about the mother and the father which i
frankly i don't think we have to make
that much of and the translation can be
a little bit misleading it has an actual
view clique mother
but it has an implicit anzik zayinda
father rather father who exists in
itself
and then he says here's the real payoff
actuality
vehicle
or self-consciousness
for actuality or self-consciousness and
the in itself as substance
are its two moments through whose
reciprocal externalization or alienation
right
each becoming the other spirit comes
into existence as this their
unity
so spirit is
connecting together all of this i do
want to return though to one thing that
i mentioned at the beginning
this is both
for gestalt which means it is being
placed in representation for us right as
we have it in the book
but it we're also conceptualizing this
right in the previous paragraph hegel
said
that the you know all of this uh
constitutes the notion
or the production of it in principle
this is how we move beyond just in
principle to conceptualizing these
matters so this is part of what we need
to like keep in mind
as we're now moving forward this is sort
of a metaphysical map to what has taken
place and where we're going
you